The first teenage comic book crime-fighter not to be under the wing of an older superhero,...
...Spider-Man had to learn for himself that with great power came great responsibility.
Welcome to Watchmojo.com. I'm your host Derek Allen...
...and today, we'll be exploring why Peter Parker became Spider-Man.
To avoid confusion, it should be noted that we're following the storyline which unfolded in the comic book.
Members of the government intelligence agency, S.H.I.E.L.D.,...
...Peter Parker's parents were killed while he was still an infant.
Adopted by his Aunt May and Uncle Ben, Peter grew up fascinated with science;...
...however, also he was timid and unpopular among his friends.
While at a science exhibition, Peter was bitten by a radioactive spider, and shortly after discovers...
...he has been given a set of spider-like powers such as superhuman strength, agility, and the ability to crawl on walls,...
...as well as a strong sixth sense, usually described as his spider sense.
Peter Parker's initial reaction to these newly acquired powers is to use them for fame and fortune.
However, one night during the television special,...
...Peter allows a thief to escape the TV station, claiming it was not his problem.
The same thief goes on to kill Peter's uncle in a mugging.
The guilt from knowing he could have prevented his uncle's death leads Peter to turn to a life of crime fighting...
...and is arguably the main basis for his moral core.